sur tmx et face à bath et le troisième
numéro avec marine le pen il ya eu eric
zemmour qui est venu nous voir jean luc
mélenchon valérie pécresse
malheureusement
y eut annulé alors viendra peut-être
voilà ce que pour l'instant la de la
poudre aux yeux et que la poudre rose
aujourd'hui j'espère que ça va aller
mieux mais reviendra nous voir bientôt
on l'espère et pour l'instant nous
sommes avec marine le pen en direct
comment ça va ça se passe bien vous êtes
heureux d'être avec nous alors nous vous
regrettez pas non pas du tout vous êtes
bien là non non je suis très bien tout
va bien on va tenir jusqu'à 2 heures du
matin alors non monsieur vous que ça oui
ça vous connaissez ça peut se terminer
en boîte de nuit un des jeux venus
souvent très tard dites-moi marine le
pen alors j'y joue le jeu je me suis
retiré ça vous met vraiment en préparant
les missions et c'est vrai que vous
n'avez pas de premier homme si vous êtes
élu non ça fait trois ans vous dit que
vous cherchez l'amour non vous cherchez
pas non je pensait le trouver non vous
serez seul vous serez seul à l'elysée
oui oui oui oui ah oui on dit quoi je
serais pas de faux d'accord on a vu pas
mal du foin dans les derniers mandats
moi je ferai pas de faux
voilà je suis célibataire je suis
célibataire vous le palais de saddam 2
millions de français qu'ils le sont
aussi et en 2020 en 2022 en france c'est
pas non plus un inconvénient je pense
qu'on une société moderne et que l'idée
qu'il faille absolument être accompagné
quelqu'un pour entrer à l'élysée
m'apparaît pour le coup un peu une idée
poussiéreuse ça va être grand quand même
tout seul là bas pour vous mais j'ai
tous mes sens tant ça oui c'est moche
mais ça fait du monde donc on risque pas
de vous voir en scooter avec des
croissants il ya peu de chance
un
peu de chance ok très bien aller
monde